I've been eager to talk to this to this
guy for for quite some time pre-draft
post draft and now right here in the
middle of June kind for Daniel Jones to
spend some of his downtime before the
season here on the Rich Eisen show how
you doing Daniel I'm doing great how you
doing rich I am doing just fine this is
just gonna be a nice Michigan dude chat
right now that's the only animus I bring
to this equation right now okay this
Michigan and Duke you know all right
but even though even though that
probably doesn't you're probably too
young to remember the the Fab five and
stuff like that right yeah I've seen the
I've seen 30 for 30 but yeah do you have
any relationship with the basketball
team at all Coach K any anything like
that Daniel we've we've heard Coach K
speak he's come and you know spoken to
our team a couple times but you know
I've gotten to know some of the guys
over the years but you know it's kind of
you know it's a new team every year and
but you know they're they're good guys
always a lot of fun a lot of fun
watching those guys how did you wind up
at Duke so I grew up in Charlotte North
Carolina which is about two hours from
Duke so I kind of grew up in the area
watched what coach Scott did with the
program and and you know was was
attracted to Duke for a number of
reasons but coach Scott being a being a
big big part of that and kind of
identified as a place I wanted to go and
you know my recruiting worked out you
know a little bit differently a little
bit slower but I found my way the air
coach gave me a gave me a shot and it
was a you know a good deal for me yeah
David Cutcliffe you referring to the
coach there at Duke what what did he
bring out of you that you're taking to
the NFL you know I think there's there's
a lot I think you know I think his his
reputation and and you know just just
him being known for for being able to
develop quarterbacks I think is you know
is this certainly you know true and
something I was fortunate enough to
experience I think he's you know the way
he teaches quarterbacks the way he
coaches you know quarterbacks to to
understand an offense well
you know installing an offense and
understanding it and then you know
playing the game and processing
information thinking through reads and
you know that kind of stuff I think I
think that's you know that was real for
me and having that experience at Duke
learning that you know I'd Duke is uh
you know it helped me so far and
hopefully helps me here here down the
road yeah here down the road right there
in the New York metropolitan area Daniel
Jones on the Rich Eisen show so you're
drafting into New York City Dave get him
on the general manager giant said it
took three snaps at the senior ball to
fall in love with you were you aware of
those three snaps Daniel at the time no
I'm uh I'm not sure what what three
snaps they were but yeah I mean I think
throughout the process getting to know
mr. gentleman you know coach tremor
everyone here with the giant
organization now certainly you know felt
felt like you know those meetings were
well I really enjoyed the you know the
opportunity to get to know those guys
and and you know glad it worked out Wade
then yeah and your relationship with Eli
Manning how would you describe that so
far Daniel I mean I think it's been I
think it's been great you know to have
the opportunity to be sitting next to
him in meetings and in here and you know
the things he's thinking about you know
after practice before practice and kind
of just his routine I think is a is an
awesome opportunity and he's been you
know he's been awesome so far so any I
mean it's been great and you know I
think we've got a great quarterback room
with with you know Kyle and Alex as well
so you know we're all we're all helping
each other and then try and do what we
can to win some football games so how
much brain picking are you doing a good
bit I mean I think you know I think I'd
be you know I think I'd be making
mistake if I'd if I didn't take
advantage of that so you know he's been
he's been very helpful to me and I'm
certainly you know not not shy to ask
questions when something comes up well
what can you give me a one item so far
that Eli Manning has volunteered to you
over the first few weeks of working out
with him and being a teammate with him
that has been helpful for your
maturation and development Daniel Jones
yeah I mean I think a big part of it is
the pre practice routine and you know
kind of getting the script and kind of
rehearsing those situations in your head
and making sure you're you've drawn up
the place and you're clear on what you
know what is your going to be running
and you know all the variations of there
are all the adjustments within the play
that you could need to make I mean I
think just kind of that pre practice
routine of preparation and and how to
approach you know these these spring
practices so far has been helpful and
just trying to yeah that certainly
learned a lot from that and the way he's
prepared and kind of how he gets ready
for practice sure and then you know I'm
not telling he tales out of school
you're clearly a smart guy going to Duke
and you have two ears I mean the the
reaction has not been all positive to
your drafting in New York and here you
are being drafted you can't control any
of that what what how have you dealt
with that from hearing it for the first
time - currently right now Daniel yeah I
mean I think it's you know I certainly
don't pay a whole lot of attention to it
but but like you said I mean I think you
know you're aware of it and you know I'm
focused on what on what we're doing here
and then focused on I'm trying to you
know trying to practice as well as I
could these past six weeks and you know
saw some progress you know over these
six weeks so I mean at the end of the
day I'm uh you know grateful to be part
of this franchise do this opportunity
and you know I'm looking looking forward
to you know keeping it and keep it going
well every quarterback I've met Daniel
is a control freak and then deep down a
competitor a real red ass competitor I'm
wondering if you internalize any of what
we've just discussed for when you first
take a snap in real live action for the
Giants you know I'm not sure you know
I'd certainly and certainly say I'm a
I'm a competitor and you know all those
things but but I'm not sure I'm you know
gonna internalize it or really you know
see it that way
you know I think you know I mean over
this
over this you know a period of time
certainly not a lot of people you know
bringing it up and you know I'd like I
said I've just I just feel fortunate to
be in this vision fortunate to be you
know here as a member of the Giants so
it's like I said I'm looking forward to
the opportunity so a couple more minutes
left with daniel Jones Giants
quarterback here what a lot has been
discussed about what Pat Shermer said
when breaking for the summer that the
best player suited for the job ready for
the job is going to get the job do you
think you can be ready for the job week
one Daniel I don't mean I don't know I
think I think everyone on our team is
trying to prove that you know they can
play and you know everyone wants to play
so you know I think when when coach said
that I think that's that's what any
coach does you know at any level in any
sport so I think I think you know like I
said it sir it's it's all of our goals
to prove that we can play it's you know
rookies veterans everyone wants to wants
to be on the field so you know we'll see
how it works out but you know I'm
excited to you know get a little bit
time off here but I'm excited to get
back and then get to work
have you been specifically told you can
start this year you know that hasn't
been you know no one's no one said in
anything like that but you know like
like I said I think I think we're just
you know trying to kind of do all we can
to make sure this team's ready to play
in August okay and last thing or your
personal life are you all set up you got
a spot you're ready to go I mean used to
do settled in are you a New Jersey I to
New Yorker what are you are you I
haven't figured out quite yet I'm gonna
be be working on I've started working on
that a little bit but yeah probably
probably stay around here and in New
Jersey I think is what most people end
up doing okay okay have you been told
you sound like Eli like literally sound
like him I know that people think that
you have the same look in the helmet and
body language have you been told by Jeff
Daniel I've been told that one year that
one's new maybe I don't know what that
what that could be but um okay now that
one's new I'll get out
the first on that rebel plant the flag
on that Daniel like I said I've been
eager to talk to you it's a fascinating
story that you have and a remarkable
opportunity that you're going to have
whenever that is and I look forward to
watching what you do with it thank you I
appreciate it rich thanks crabman you
bet that's daniel Jones Giants
quarterback here on the Rich Eisen show
at Daniel underscored Jones 10 for more
of the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
Live or download the Rich Eisen show app